sari hello another great question why
write and try to get my work out there
if the chances of it being optioned or
even read is extremely Slim in the real
world well that's a good question I got
the answer to that so okay cuz uh you're
right it may never get R there it may
not be op might not be optioned it might
not get out but what I've learned
through tons of failures and a couple of
kind of successes is to embrace the
process and not only embrace the process
just realize
that you're a writer so you wake up
every day as a writer and I had someone
asked me they're like oh how do you get
your inspiration I'm like inspiration
what no I just write it's I have a
routine I have these three structural
things that I do and then I get to my
work and it's just and I do it every day
and the beauty of that is the process so
nobody can take the process of writing
away from you so you just keep crafting
story crafting story and even when um
even when good things happen like I was
when we had our premiere of uh
Confessions of a Teenage Jesus jerk and
you I got to do Q&A and it was just it
was such an uplifting point and then the
next day I was depressed and I was like
well that's the end of that but I
learned a valuable lesson there no it's
not the end of that it's tomorrow I get
to work on the other thing I'm working
on the next thing so more important than
the outcome is the process and you have
to love the process so if you you just
and you have to love storytelling it's
it's if it's your religion you're going
to show up every day to it and um
whether there's an outcome or not and
then uh like when it like playing the
lottery you got to be in it to win it
right so in order to write in order to
have stuff to to show people you have to
have a lot of writing to show people
that's
finished and that and you may be put in
a good position more often than not
where people go oh send me what you have
and if you have a lot of stuff because
you've been working hard for a long time
you have things to show them and that's
where the doors open um when there's
things to show them I hope I hope that
helps your question but the real world
is being at your desk writing every day
which is such a luxury and a cool thing
to do in life I it's my favorite thing
to do so and you Rite in coffee shops a
lot too don't you Tony yeah I do a lot
of handwriting in coffee shops I I'm the
guy that never brings a laptop and I
also really hate doing and we're in La
so I hate writing screenplays in coffee
shops I write novels in coffee shops and
then if I'm if I'm working on a
screenplay I'll handr write the
screenplay at a coffee shop on a yellow
pad and then bring it home home and type
it in um that's my own weird Quirk but
um yeah I just I love the long hand and
then I print out I go home type it
keyboard it all in print it all out then
bring the print out the next day and
sometimes the print out gets bigger and
bigger and bigger and before you know it
I have a binder that I'm doing rewrites
on and it's uh so whatever project
that's happening early stages is yellow
pads later stage stages is
binder oh and going back to what sari is
saying did anybody say the same thing to
you like hey Tony that there's so little
chances of this why do it wh why why
waste your time with this well well I
mean I kind of grew up in a religion
where you weren't supposed to do
anything but you know preach so I um so
that's a little weird CU I was doing
something that was so not what you were
supposed to do so I had to fight through
that uh people making fun of me for
writing and trying to write um sometimes
that's good cuzz sometimes I feel like
people should tease people a little bit
to see if the resolve is there and if
you can get past those people going you
can't write what do you do what do you
think you are you're writing what do you
you're out of your mind you can't be a
writer and then you get past them then
and it's almost like that you walked
through that first obstacle you had the
conflict you walked through your own
first obstacle and you're like I'm
writing uh Lort hello from Britain I'm
writing my first TV series I'm halfway
through episode three of about six and
I'm really losing motivation to write oh
that's a good question how do you
self-motivate during moments of
self-doubt thank you yeah I lose
interest too in stuff that's a great
question I love this question so all
this question says to me is you're a
writer it's it's um we the getting
through the mo self motivation and
getting through the self-doubt is what
writers do to get to their end and and
that's why people find it so hard to
write because you're going to hit that
wall and it's it's almost like you just
got to show up with that self-doubt one
thing I try to do I'll work on a
different project if I'm having a really
hard time with a current like if I'm
halfway through a a project I'll do some
short little writing thing that may
never ever get published or or maybe
even WR outside of what with those
characters of something else um just to
kind of bring some freshness back to it
and then just and then you got to come
back in and just feel like an impostor
and feel like there's just no way uh
you're going to do anything right but
you continue to just plug away and ask
questions well where would it where does
this go here and I'll even write the
questions I'll just be like um I'll have
my characters ask me questions I'll I'll
write their questions down and then I
try to answer to them and that has
gotten me out of some uh some stuck
places as well so it's it's uh just I
what your question just proves you're a
writer so and prove it even more to get
to episode 6 with all that self-doubt
and that hard motivation to sit down
with it every day I love that and you
know sometimes it seems like if things
are messy around us maybe it's time to
just kind of like clean them up and then
make sure everything is like within its
place and we can kind of get a new spark
again I don't know that's yeah that's
declutter right that's the Marine
there's declutter and then there's
repainting to avoid oh okay okay so then
some of it might be avoidance all right
maybe I'm giving bad advice no you're
not that's actually no that is something
to shake it up we would that that would
I would think that's shaking up our
environment you know shake up the
environment even more and go to a park
and right for a while and see if that
you know works it may not work may be a
very bad idea and is that what helps you
being in coffee shops because it's such
a different environment every day um
yeah and I plus people irritate me so uh
in coffee shops I get a little irritated
and then that I don't know what it is
and I never really put my finger on the
why but it just
um and it's I think I need to be vaguely
irritated in order to be selfmotivated
interesting which is kind of great in I
like that Society cuz you could you be
irritated with anything sure sure
especially La is very crowded yeah yeah
yeah yeah V Martin hello from Deep South
Texas when did you realize slash accept
oh I like that accept that you were a
writer did you have the conflict
deciding between the artistic life and
being a quote Normie okay well I got an
answer we had this we actually had this
conversation before we started started y
I have an answer to that question I used
to be an Normie I'm still kind of I'm
still kind of a normie um I read a I
read I and I may have said this actually
when we interviewed before but um
there's a book by new hamson called
hunger and I read that and and I've been
reading for a while but I've been
working also in like Tech and things
like that and also doing like College
radio I was kind of like floundering
around and when I read that I I realized
oh man I got to I got a I got to write
and that's when I um quit my tech job
and started cuz the tech job was fun but
it was life consuming so instead of
doing Tech I just went and did temp work
and was a file Clerk or whatever so I
can just leave it at work and come home
and write um and that's when I that's
when I
decided that uh that I'm going to be a
writer uh till the death and and um and
it was a very poor decision and I should
have stayed in Tech financially now for
soul for for my soul it was everything I
needed to do and so I feel very lucky
and um yeah so just just see just see if
it see if um see if you see if you need
to tell your stories not everyone needs
to tell their stories uh for me I need
to tell my stories it's it's urgent when
when I wake up in the morning that I
have stories in progress and I am so
happy that that's my life was there was
it building up to many years of you
deciding to leave the tech industry or
was it a fast exit it's the kind of it
was I was in it for about two two and a
half years it was pretty fast um and I
just realized it wasn't me I do love and
that here's the um I love solving
problems I love puzzles and you can do
that in TCH and you can also do that in
writing cuz in writing all we're doing
is when our on our first draft we're
creating problems we we're just creating
huge problems for ourselves that we need
to fix almost like if we were debugging
software we need to debug our um our our
writing to make it better and continue
to work on the puzzle which is how do I
make this as perfect as I can make
it